but Quorum a finance committee will come
to order we're here to get the briefing
from the hard-working
legislative budget assistant and his
staff that have been working all night
to make sure we were fully informed of
all the work we have done in this last
few weeks so
Mr Kane you are
recognized
for a thank you good morning Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is Michael Keane I'm the
legislative budget assistant
um and before I start I just have to
really thank Lobster legislative
Services what got us out of here at a
good time last night so we didn't have
they had a great turnaround on household
one and two uh very large documents so
just want to thank them before you you
have three documents you have a surplus
statement which is a nine page document
and you have Amendment
1244h which is an amendment to House
Bill 1A that's your operating budget and
then you have an amendment
1247h which is your amendment to House
Bill 2 uh when I say your Amendment
based on all the actions you've taken to
date
quickly just on House Bill one you'll
notice it's pretty small this is in a
format it's a strikeout insert format uh
pretty hard to read the clerks do like
this they don't have to print the whole
800 page document but just so you know
once this is approved by the committee
on our website we will put up a compare
report which is easier for the members
and the public to read and to see the
differences between the governor on in
the house finance position
up
so just to get right into the Surplus
statement you are balanced this based on
all the actions uh taken in the house
finance committee the combined General
and education trust fund is a balanced
spending plan right now uh 23
you can see that house finance ends with
a balance of about 44 million dollars in
the general fund which based on statute
would be transferred into their any day
fund bringing the balance to about 203.9
million as we sit here today the rainy
day fund balance is 159.9 so you'd bring
it up over 200 million with your
proposals
an FY 2024 for house finance
you do end with a balance after transfer
of about
164.7 million dollars since that is the
middle year of the biennium anything
carries forward into Row one on the top
of um
under 25 so that's your beginning
balance as you combined beginning
balance for General and education trust
fund and I'll get into the various funds
as we move forward uh based on the uh
the revenues as adopted by house Ways
and Means or proposed by house waste
means and house resolution 17 as well as
the revenue adjustments and the
Amendments contained in house bill 2.
you have about 3.1 billion dollars in
Revenue offset by about 3.2 million
billion dollars in expenditures
resulting in a cumulative ending balance
with that balance forward of about 52.2
million dollars at the end of 25. again
based on statute any balance remaining
in the general fund at the end of the
biennium would be transferred to the
rainy day fund that 52.2 million would
be transferred to the rainy day fund
resulting in a balanced estimated
balance at the end of 25 of about 256
million dollars
if we go I'm just going to not go
through all the pages of the Surplus
statement
just high level
how does the general fund
um compare to where the governor came
you'll see two large
differences between the governor as you
know you had a discussion relative to
revenue that goes into the general fund
and education trust fund the house did
propose to move an additional
um I think it was almost 300 million
dollars in education trust and revenue
to the general fund the reason for that
was to fund to also move the School
building Aid and a couple other programs
but then to allow for available funds to
fund other
um
requests in your other divisions
division three had a almost a 70 million
dollar increase for Medicaid rates that
they needed to fund so when you look on
your line six review total revenues you
can see 23 is the same that's based on
current law but you can see the
difference between the revenues between
the governor and the house after you
account for all the adjustments house
about almost 2.1 billion dollars in
Revenue versus 1.9 for the governor in
24 about 2.1 in 25 versus the governors
of 1.9 and 25.
offset by expenditures about two billion
dollars in house finance and 24
resulting in an ending balance of about
86 million dollars uh in 24. that
carries forward onto Row one and then if
you go through the uh the sheet again it
will bring you down to a positive
balance of 94.7 it does uh the proposed
plan does require a transfer to the
education trust fund of 42.5 million
resulting in an ending balance of 52.2
which again goes into the general fund
page three is just your base Revenue
estimates you remember that discussion
on the house floor the house ways means
presented their revenue estimates this
is just your base Revenue estimates and
you can see where the differences are
there for the journal fund
page four beginning on page four is what
we call our schedule two we pay a lot of
attention to this a lot of the updates
we've been providing throughout the um
your discussions have used a lot of
these adjustments your swim split
communication Services tax
decisions interests and dividends taxes
multi-state Auditors and then some uh
yes I have a question over here sure
some Edwards
uh thank you Mr chair I I'm just looking
at uh page three on uh line seven for
interest in dividends tax I'm going over
to the right where it says fy25 yep uh
both the governor and the house finance
uh is is using the same Revenue
projection of 89.4 million yes and and I
unders I thought I understood that one
of the effects of an hb2 item related to
the IND tax might influence this number
yes these are the base Revenue estimates
based on current law what if you return
to page four
and on row five
all the way over to the left hand right
hand side you can see a reduction of
17.4 million dollars so that has been
taken out of those estimates we keep the
estimates on the schedule one identical
to base thank you so much sure
and then your appropriation adjustments
I'll just go over a few there are many
pages of appropriation adjustments
um the first one I just want to point
out is 23 if you look on row 11 your
statutory fiscal governor and Council
estimated Appropriations when the
governor had released his budget in
February there are about 15.9 million
dollars of Appropriations based on
actions of fiscal and actions through
statute with these open warrants there
was about 25.7 million dollars so that
was almost a 9 million dollar hit that
the um almost a 10 million hit that the
house finance committee needed to take
this is a number that will change
throughout the process it will change
from the Senate process it will change
prior to the close of the fiscal year in
June so that's just a number that you
had to account for
legislative Specialists from 2022 the
governor in the house have the same
numbers at about
265.2 and then you have individual
um
individual pieces of legislation on row
14 15 and 16 you have Senate bill one
which is your new Services Center you
have House Bill 384 which is the
legislative parking garage which was
22.5 million which was offset with
you'll see a schedule 2 adjustment down
below because the governor had initially
proposed to fund that in his budget and
then the adult parole board was about a
hundred and three thousand dollars
what we did is from rows 18 down we put
it in Department we combine them by
department so you can see for the
various departments what was provided
with Appropriations if there's a zero
next to the governor's amount that means
that the house took it out so that in 23
if we turn to page I believe it's page
six
in total house finance uh appropriation
adjustments totaled about
529.7 million dollars as compared to the
governors of about
505.6 one of the largest appropriation
adjustments the house took was 50
million dollar appropriation towards the
unfunded accrue liability in 23 and
that's why you see uh partial of that
difference you'll know as you went
through divisions how you reduce some
Appropriations in 23 and that helped to
offset that impact of that I'm going to
stay on page six and just go through the
governor had about 133.9 million of
appropriation adjustments in 24 versus
the house of
135.6 again the divisions we're going
through as they were developing their
budget trying to offset any additions
with corresponding reductions another
question sure because I'm Emerick
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question is there any way in
here that reflects the pay raises or is
it through wild yes so on page
we haven't got to it yet then don't
worry about it it's in there uh it could
be on page four it's on page four
on row 21 you'll remember the governor
appropriated in general funds to sell
all General funds 44.9 million dollars
and 24
54.7 million and 25 the house maintained
those Appropriations so you can see the
corresponding numbers under the house
column as well thank you sure so it's
about 100 million over the by any
thank you uh Mr chair and thank you Mr
Kane so so they're on schedule two on
page four line 21.
um
do these do these numbers that are
reflected there end up in hb1 or do they
just live here in hb2 at what point in
other words what point do do these 10
affect the salary line in hb1 could
could you go through that sure uh so
typically these will remain in House
Bill 2 as the block Appropriations when
the budget is passed at the end of June
administrative services in the executive
branch then start to roll these figures
up into house bill one or the operating
budget so you'll on that date so in July
right in on July 1 those figures will be
rolled up to all the individual
departments uh what they do is they draw
warrants which is basically allocations
to each department on what their share
is when you in 26 and 27 when you look
at the budget they will be in house bill
one any pay raises will be in household
one
thank you sure
Mr chairman
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman so this is only General funds
but I believe there's roughly 150
million similar in other and federal
funds
of pay raises and my colleague is giving
me a picture
yeah yes so so
um because a lot of employees are paid
you know like in HHS there's 50 50s and
things like that so the total amount of
pay raises is more like 250 million or
something in that bumper
foreign
yes there's all those dot employees paid
out of the highway fund
yes and on page 72 on your Amendment you
don't have to go there if you unless you
want to but in total the pay raises are
about 101.5 million all funds in 24 and
about 124 million in 25 so about 225
million in total funds of which the
journal fund has about 100 million of
that
okay
so those are your adjustments which all
been reflected on page one and page two
if you turn to page seven this is the
education trust fund
thank you
so in 23 uh the the only differences uh
between the governor and the house
finance committee proposal are really
your house Ways and Means Revenue
estimates you can see on our Row 4 your
estimated revenues Governor had about
100 1.2 billion dollars whereas house
finance or house ways it means had about
1.17 so it was about a 30 million dollar
difference in revenues you can see the
Appropriations were about the same but
that Revenue did result in a change to
the current year balance and your
cumulative ending balance so the
governors based on his Revenue estimates
had the education trust fund ending 23
and beginning 24 since the education
trust fund isn't a non-lapsing
in at the end of 23 at 221 million the
house finance had 183.8 million dollars
and that was just related to the revenue
estimates and again that will change as
we go through the process
if we go into fy24 you can see on Row
one the beginning balances how there is
a difference because of those initial
Revenue estimates and then you have your
estimated revenues
um another on row four between the house
ways means and the governor another 30
or so million dollar uh below the
governor your schedule for adjustments
are where you see your adjustments to
your general fund and education trust
fund tax splits for the business taxes
Governor initially had 75 million
dollars which was based on his 65 35
split house finance has a 77.5 22.5
split between the general education
trust fund so that's a negative
adjustment of 223 million dollars so
your total revenue for house finance a
little over a billion dollars
uh budget Appropriations on line nine
in 24 the governor had about 1.2 billion
dollars of Education trust fund
expenditures you can see the house has
about 1.1 billion dollars for Education
trust fund expenditures uh reason for
that is because with the general fund
move that Revenue also went School
building Aid and other programs that
weren't related to adequacy Charter
Schools or education Freedom accounts
so in the end the cumulative ending
balance if you count the 183.7 million
dollars coming forward from 23 uh you
offset it against a negative current
year balance of about 105. still have a
positive balance the education trust
funded about 78.4 and that's after
moving all the revenue and it's some
expenditures
that's 78.4 carries forward into the
beginning of 25 and then you can see the
adjustments as well on row five in the
far right about
224.8 for the house finance committee
compared to the governor's 74.8
resulting in total revenues of about
1.048 billion dollars offset on row nine
by about 1.1 million dollars in
expenditures
um and then you can see on 10 the big
change in fiscal year 25s the governor
initially had a 75 million uh dollar
appropriation to school building aid
from the education trust fund on June
30th 25 so it wouldn't be until the end
of biennium based on the house finance
actions they had removed that additional
75 million but you can see a 20 million
dollar adjustment and you can see that
on the fall on I believe it's on page
nine but just to stay on page seven for
now that 20 million and the 10 million
in 24 has to do with an adjustment that
division two felt prudent to make into
account for set aside for the increased
free and reduced population based on an
action taken by fiscal committee uh
earlier this year where it increased
your free and reduced lunch eligibility
was not accounted for in the governor's
proposal it is just an it's a set aside
or accounting for that potential impact
act from the house the house finance
committee's budget
so in the end with the change in the
revenues the Appropriations Uh current
year balance of a negative 121 it does
require transfer from the general fund
of about 42.5 million dollars to bring
the balance to zero at the end of 25.
and then your car your page eight and
nine are really just uh they're
mimicking your your general fund
um kind of your order and your detail
where you have your revenues and then
you have your adjustments uh so
this is a balanced uh spending plan for
that's house finance right now has uh
based on this and I can answer any
questions that anyone has
any questions from committee members
push the red light if you have a
question
a lot of back and forth on all these
schedules a lot of busy work to make
them all come out right yes so
no questions okay thank you on please
thank you
um so that's all I have for my
presentation and then we will be I'll
still be here as you have your
conversations if there are any um
additional detail that you need from me
Mr chairman I'll ask a question
representative McGuire thank you will
you have a surplus statement for the
highway fund and others yes thanks uh
thank you for asking representative
McGuire so we will post a surplus
statement for the highway fund and the
Fish and Game fund which are one pagers
so you'll probably enjoy reading those
more uh just to give you kind of as far
as a balanced Highway and Fish and Game
Highway fund ends with a balance of
about 7.2 million dollars I think the
governor was about 13 but you'll
remember in fiscal you just had to give
6 million towards winter maintenance
um and then the fish and game fund ends
almost identical to where the governor
was about 4.5 million dollars at the end
of um 25 and we will post those to our
website after this meeting today thanks
further questions
okay I guess you're going to brief HP
one or hb2 or some of the other people
going to do that that's all I have for
my presentation now
so
um these other packets those that
sure sorry so the other packets 12 4 4H
are your house bill one amendments so
that's your big operating budget
document uh so if adopted those will be
folded into the budget system
um
it's kind of a hard document to read
as far as being user friendly we will
post a compare report which is a
document that I think the legislature
and the public find more useful but this
is the actual the the legislation or the
legislative amendment that is in
hb2 has been shortened up considerably
it has we're able to staple it so you
remember when you received yeah when you
when you received House Bill 2 we had to
staple it was over 200 pages in our
copier can staple up to 100 so it didn't
work
um you have brought this down to close
to 140 Pages the big one of the big
changes you made was in division one
relative to some of the oplc changes uh
that removed
a considerable amount of uh paper so yes
so in House Bill 2 this reflects all
your changes that were adopted in your
individual House Bill two Amendment
packets that you've taken over the past
couple of days we did look over this
with OLS and our staff to ensure that we
did catch everything and we're confident
that everything is reflected here as
well as any Appropriations are captured
on the Surplus statement on our schedule
two and four
foreign
so this is the end of all the LBA
presentations it is yes
very good
all right
so we do we need another vote on
accepting the uh
Surplus statement Surplus statement will
just reflect the intent uh how the
committee votes so you don't need to
take a vote on that uh the committee
would need to vote on 1244 H first which
is the amendment to house will one
followed by
1247h which is the amendment to house
bill 2.
okay the clerk will call a roll on House
Bill one Amendment 1244 h
onest
representative Heath thank you Mr chair
are you calling for a vote on the
amended HP one
I am
um could I make a comment first of
course thank you
um
Mr chair
there are lots of good things in this
budget
lots of good things
and it deeply
bothers me
not to be able to vote for this budget
I was hoping that we could reach some
compromises
but one of my reasons is building Aid I
wish we could find
more funding for that yesterday I tried
to get more funding for adult education
one of my bigger concerns is the amount
of money going into the afas
last year we spent 14.6 million
in this biennium budget you have 29.8
and 24
29.25 to the f8
oh EFA efas
um
I've continually asked that the
oversight for these go to the Department
of Ed even if they RFP it out to the
current agency
I'm deeply concerned that's over almost
60 million dollars going out
I'm pleased with the increase in tuition
and transportation that's wonderful
but but Mr chair
there were just some things in this
budget that right now
if we could come to a compromise I would
feel so much better about some of these
items
that at this point in time I just can't
vote on this budget as much as I want to
I mean the raises for our state workers
are critical and it is intensely painful
for me not to step forward and vote for
that
so Mr a chair if there's any way that we
could delay the vote
um to do some further negotiations I
would ask for that option if it is all
possible
thank you Mr chair
representative Edwards
I I I don't know if this is for for you
Mr chair or for Mr Kane but if we ended
up with the legislature unable to agree
to a budget this year and we had to go
into a continuing resolution what what
happens to hb2 does this does this just
get set aside and not go into effect
what I mean what what happens in a
continuing resolution relative to hb2
it depends uh the continuing resolution
at the end of the process is really a
negotiation that comes between house
senate House and Senate leadership and
the governor and both a majority and
minority parties uh there's no
um
one answer on what the continuing
resolution can do it can appropriate the
same level of funds received last year
it could include Provisions uh
potentially Provisions related in-house
Bill 2 but typically historically since
I have been here it has not included any
provisions that are included in House
Bill too but again that's something that
will be discussed with leadership as we
go through
Mr chair
I would request if I may
I would request that we recess
until one o'clock this afternoon
I know there are further negotiations
going on between the two parties so
I will uh exceed to your request and
otherwise we'll have to come back
tomorrow
if we can't come to an agreement
so
for four hours
well that's a suggestion too if we
have a suggestion
we come back tomorrow because otherwise
we all sit here waiting for some results
from negotiations
and I tie up your whole day
which may go beyond one o'clock so
and I don't think I don't think there
will be any
movement and negotiations I think that
some of the requests are intractable
representative thank you Mr chair
um I just wanted to suggest that
personally I already kind of assumed
I'll be here all day today but I
definitely did not assume I'll be here
tomorrow I will be here tomorrow of
course if needed but if there is any way
in which this can get uh
dealt with today uh I think that it
would be ideal but as I said whatever
needs to be done
representative Edward
um you know it seems to me uh given how
little progress there was made yesterday
in the negotiations that uh today could
really take a long time just to have
those discussions and uh in order to
allow for the the folks in the crowd and
the rest of us to figure out what we're
doing I I do I do think the idea to
recess until tomorrow morning has a
great deal of validity
anyone object to coming back tomorrow
representative Griffin
yeah I I just like to say that I listen
carefully to Representatives he's
Remax and I suspect that all of us in
this room
have areas of these budget documents
that we're unhappy about
but I think overall I think it's a
wonderful budget
there's a compromises in there everybody
gave a little bit
um and I I see no
representative emmerich
thank you Mr chair
I'm of the opinion that Finance should
vote
and then if negotiations resolve
anything it goes to the house as a floor
Amendment
or an amendment in in the calendar
we have one member absent
so if if he's better
maybe we have a full committee tomorrow
when we come back so
I will take the advice and we will
recess until 10 o'clock tomorrow
Dan McGuire
thank you